welcome back spring is here which means
we are all in need of a good spring
cleaning and that's how Zerorez the
sponsors of today's segment can help
welcome back to our friend of the show
Ben McKee so great to see you Ben
absolutely thanks for being here let's
talk about spring it's an important time
year round to be clean but especially
spring cleaning why is spring so
important to make sure you're doing the
stuff right well I don't know if you
lived through like yesterday and all the
wind but apparently I know almost blew
away yesterday and that's why it's a
great time of year to clean all this
dust and all this danders blowing around
get your carpets clean it's going to
help improve the indoor air quality of
your home or your business and we even
clean air ducts too so wow you guys do
it all yeah you do it all you come into
the house and take care of everything
and what I love about what you guys do
tell us about the solutions what you
guys use it's really unlike anyone else
it is if you look at the history of
carpet cleaning it hasn't changed like
80 to 90 years people are still putting
down soaps and surfactants in their
carpet that's why your spots come back
that's why your carpets dry crunchy uh
at zero res we clean with what we call
ZR water it eliminates the soap it'll
eliminates the headache of having
crunchy carpets and it can even out
clean the soap and detergent-based
cleaners out there yeah we definitely
don't want crunchy carpet but I want to
see this up close and personal you guys
always have the best demos it's hard to
believe that you can get this to clean
and with zero rest our goal is to get
your carpet back to a like new state
um here we go now obviously we can't
reverse the wear and tear that happens
uh when we figure out how to weave new
carpet fibers in there we'll let you
know but for now we're getting rid of
the dirt the grease and the grime and
you get to tell it's almost effortless
and you guys I mean you have been around
for a while you received the top tier
Awards why do you think your customers
keep coming back they love you guys they
do love us we've been in Vegas for
nearly 20 years our cleaning is amazing
but our real asset is our team yeah we
train our team day in and day out um a
mortgage is technical knowledge of
carpet cleaning but also just how to be
good communicators how to provide the
best customer experience and that's why
we have over like 7 000 reviews online
right now incredible you guys really do
it all and we're seeing the carpet here
firsthand but do you guys work on other
materials in the house as well we do we
can clean your tile and grout we have a
whole dedicated commercial crew to work
day and night under Casino or hotel so
whatever you got just give us a call
yeah
you I have two dogs wear and tear on the
carpet should they just give you a call
and you guys will come out absolutely
call us visit us online and we'll get
you scheduled well thank you so much for
being here anyway guys always have the
best demos it's hard to believe you can
find a carpet this dirty and make it
that clean so I'm always amazed by you
guys all right all the information on
your screen thank you again to zerorest
for sponsoring this segment you can
check out their spring cleaning special
clean for as low as 35 dollars per room
plus receive free tile cleaning 100
square feet you can call
702-840-3333 or you can visit them
online at
zerorezlasvegas.com minimums apply Las
Vegas now we'll be right back